there's something about being part of
nature there's something about being
around these animals even the most
wounded veteran they feel different
keeps them part of something greater
than themselves the idea is that you've
got to give someone who's been through a
severe trauma an opportunity to heal and
we believe it
warriors and wolves program and a back
to nature setting it does that we have
40 animals at this facility there you go
you got we've rescued wolves off of
chains in Alaska as part of a roadside
attraction we rescue wolf dogs from a
backyard breeder in San Diego I think
for all the veterans that we bring out
here whether they work here or they're
here for a support group what rings true
is if they can heal I can the Wolves the
nullus you're injured or something's
wrong with you and they have the trauma
so you know we have some type of trauma
on life we can get that connection and
one wolf would be your friend for life
what happens is one animal picks that
one veteran never again does that animal
pick someone else never again does that
animal want to show the same kind of
affection to someone else what a good
boy conventional therapy isn't really
something for me didn't help to be
honest after ten years of military life
it was sort of a tough transition and I
continued down my course of being angry
drinking myself to death may have been
last chapter of my life
there are things I've seen that I can't
unsee there are things I've done that I
cannot undo just saying that well I did
it in the name of my country doesn't
help you sleep at night but what does
help you sleep is having a companion
they kind of teach you how to be calm
and confident it's it's got some deeper
meaning when they accept you they accept
you into the family part of the pack